all right mister just make me want to
like okay it's that part of the trip you
know
yes exactly truly this is the door we
are like okay okay I'm in this now hey
what's going on everybody for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by zoe kravitz she's
an actress model and musician you know
from projects like Mad Max fury road in
HBO's big little lies she also stars in
high fidelity a new series from Hulu
which is set to release on Valentine's
Day that's February 14th zoe kravitz
welcome to the show thank you for having
me how are you around spicy food how you
feeling going into this I love spice I
love spice a lot but I am scared right
now
[Music]
mm-hmm oh okay so as we mentioned you
have a new comedy show on Hulu
high-fidelity where you play this record
shop owner who is preoccupied with past
breakups mhm
I know that you're a self-described
music nerd what is the proper way to
sort records is it alphabetical
chronological or autobiographical
I mean autobiographical is pretty dope
it's also like slightly psychotic but
probably the most interesting way
because you have to remember where they
came from where you were in your life I
am NOT able to do this by the way but I
think it's a really cool thing if you
can pull it off have you ever given any
thought to that great high fidelity
quote what came first the music or the
misery have you ever given any thought
to whether or not we're miserable so we
listen to pop music or we're miserable
because we listen to pop music I think
it's a chicken or the egg situation man
I really don't think there's a proper
answer I think it's like a vicious cycle
Oh a sweet
[Music]
got a kick though I'm [ __ ] scared
right now bro one of the many amazing
videos on your Instagram is one where
you're dancing and singing along
blasting R&B and eating a burrito yes as
someone who actually grew up on a vegan
diet are we living in like a golden age
of veganism or is it kind of becoming a
parody of itself it's a good question so
I did grow up vegan I'm not vegan
anymore I'm trying to be better for the
environment people assume that I'm vegan
because I don't know they think I'm like
a hippie or something so I think I kind
of rebelled against that I mean I do
wish there was like a world where vegans
didn't have to if you go to Cafe
Gratitude or something which has
delicious food I don't want to be asked
the question of the day I just don't
want that I want right it just give me
food if you like look at places like by
Chloe or whatever there's this whole
windfall of like vegan offerings or it
could be like sloppy joes or mac and
cheese or like there's that impossible
burger yeah right so it's like this
whole new thing where it's like maybe
it's not like a health choice
necessarily or an environmental choice
necessarily like there's ten thousand
different reasons to go there I feel
like we should open like like I want to
go to like a dirty fast food vegan
restaurant like just ugly fluorescent
lighting dirty I don't want any [ __ ]
wind chimes you know what I mean like I
feel like people should be able to just
have like the McDonald's experience with
vegan food and I think that's right
around the corner we could make it
happen
speaking of right around the corner okay
[Music]
it's chill what you're scaring me I feel
like it's about to become not chill so I
suppose the people would feel
short-changed if we didn't take a moment
to discuss big little lies is the
Monterey five group chat still active it
is yeah it's so girly but I feel like
there's a lot of like I love you guys
with lots of hearts whatever happened to
that deleted scene in season two where
Reese Witherspoon nice name supposed to
throw ice cream at a Meryl Streep I
don't know I don't know why they cut it
it was such a bummer because obviously
the world needs to see that right I feel
like we should somehow release that to
the world I don't know why it was taken
out but um just knowing that Reese threw
ice cream at Meryl is good enough I
think what are the mechanics of all
those sunset scenes because it seems
like production nothing stresses him out
quite like that ticking of natural light
it's a good question you know it's funny
there never was that feeling of we're
running out of light we're freaking out
especially in season one and John Mark
who really established the natural light
look he was just very he would always
just figure it out he was always the
kind of person that would you know if if
there's no light we'll use the light
from the car that's in the parking lot
in the background he's super creative so
yeah there was never that feeling of
we're running out of time actually and
then finally costume designer
Alex Friedberg described your season one
style as NorCal bohemian and then your
season two look is careless shapeless
and depressed clothes are a huge part of
getting into character I've had certain
characters where I couldn't I didn't
really feel like that person and it's
like and I put on those clothes I felt
like oh okay I feel it now I think
that's why I love fashion so much I mean
it's it's self-expression right so how
does this person walk and talk is it's
all connected to clothing in a way
[Music]
I like this one it's just grand I just
like the flavor how do you feel about
this I like this one I'm wondering if
they were if they were swapped am i
right Chris I think it's like this Oh
have you tried them
you're right cuz this is that color
classic hot ones production mix-up I
should mention this is our first shoot
of season 11 I don't know where it's
going in the order but we got it we got
to tighten up guys we got to tighten up
mmm that's dope
that's awesome so as I understand it
you've lived in Williamsburg for ten
years and over that decade it's had a
complete transformation what is one
thing that outsiders get wrong about
Williamsburg and then what's one
stereotype that is absolutely right I
guess a lot of people think it's douche
Ville USA that's true the thing that
people get wrong is that I guess douche
Ville USA is actually kind of a nice
place to live out of curiosity have you
ever been to that hot sauce store Heat
nest I wife and they passed it I've
passed it and definitely gets my
attention and there's something about it
that makes me think it's to Williamsburg
I can't go inside I can't make myself go
inside I'm like of course there's like a
[ __ ] hot sauce store here what
neighborhood do you think has more
influence on style in 2020 Williamsburg
or Calabasas huh
Calabasas because those people have more
followers which is the better city to be
a musician LA or New York New York if
you could import one la institution to
Brooklyn what would it be
[Music]
sushi Park sushi Park you're heard it
here first
are you ready to move on down the line
yeah zoe kravitz all right so this one
is the Loews calientes Rojo
[Music]
other than who so we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
Graham where we have our guests explain
some of the deep dive pictures on their
Instagram but I want to start with your
bio which is try not to be an [ __ ]
since 1988 mm-hmm how's that going for
you it's like a day-by-day thing yeah I
mean I think like most people I can be
kind of an [ __ ] sometimes you know
social media people often try to appear
perfect and I guess that's me saying I'm
not perfect in fact I'm a little bit of
an [ __ ] but I'm trying not to be and
that's kind of the journey of life and
that's what's important
all right on to the pictures Zoe here
you are with an owl on your head is not
one of those owl cafe it is indeed I
went to Japan I heard about these al
cafes and I was fascinated and shit's
crazy man you like sit there and they
give you tea and then they they just put
the Owls on you in different places and
it's it's an owl cafe it's weird I've
always understood
owls to be like semi dangerous birds of
prey they probably could scratch their
[ __ ] the claws on that thing I looked
pretty chill but I was not chill I was
freaking out a little bit in that
picture all right this next picture
feels like it could use some explanation
so when I was a kid I was really Spears
fanatic for obvious reasons and my
father was really good is really good
friends with Mark Seliger the
photographer who took this photo and he
came into town and surprised me and
brought me to the photo shoot to me
Brittany and the oops I did it again
cover shoot yeah it's [ __ ] iconic and
then finally we have one more for you
haters will say it's photoshopped okay
so when we were shooting season 2 we
were in Monterey and we had a Midway
party where we went bowling and I went
to go get chili nandai more beer and
then I guess they took the photo while I
was gone and then this photo got posted
on Instagram and went totally viral and
I was like [ __ ] man you go to the bar
for five minutes and they cut you out of
the pan
the photo so then um yeah I photoshopped
myself into the photo cuz I'm I'm a
loser who's the best bowler in this
group
maybe Rhys not Nicole Meryl was pretty
good but [ __ ] Matt Merrill's good at
everything it's upsetting I think she
whenever she got a gutter we were all
like yes because it was so nice to see
her not like get an award for best
bowler or something
[Music]
who's it creeping for you it's creeping
for me I'm scared and how chill I feel
right now I feel like I'm gonna die
Karma's gonna [ __ ] me up on the second
half of him despite you and your family
being considered the paradigm of cool
across generations I've heard you say
that you relate more to being a nerd or
like a goofball do you think that it's
maybe impossible for anyone to think of
their parents as being cool no matter
what the outside world thinks of them I
think when you're younger yes now I
think my parents are very cool for
probably different reasons that the rest
of the world does but um yeah as a kid
there's just there's just no way you
cannot win I mean my father would do
cool things like bring me to you know
see Britney Spears but I was probably
like tad take off the netted shirt man
like what are you doing you know a lot
of times I think people rebelled because
their parents are so categorically
uncool uh-huh do you think that maybe
there's a part of you that would rebel
because they were too cool I mean I used
to joke about being a lawyer I didn't
get tattoos for till I was 19 or 20
that was rebellion right cuz you almost
want to go the opposite direction you
can't get a tattoo and it won't piss
them off it'd be like oh cool would you
go to what you get you know it's like
there's nowhere to go you know what I
think this is like I was looking I was
like I have three laughs but there's
four sauces it's Dave I feel like this
show is like doing drugs with somebody
right it's like a psychedelic experience
but also in the way where you sit down
with someone and you know you're about
to go through something together right
and you're kind of talking each other
through it I'm like a shaman yes you're
spicy food trip here all right all right
this one stargazer speaking of trippy
all right
vegan winds are very spongy but they're
chewy [ __ ] mm-hmm
so we had Shia LaBeouf on the show who
he gave us some advice for finding the
right kind of vintage tea unpredictably
he said that the key is to look for
shape that's true like some t-shirts are
too boxy it's usually how they fit in
the armpit I feel like you want them to
be slimming I go to thrift stores it's a
really cool place here in LA called um
filth mark that's really cool and
nowadays you can look on Instagram too
and if there's something that I want
specifically I'll start looking at eBay
and [ __ ] so I'm surrounded by sneaker
obsessives quite a bit in my life and
all of them seem to really respect the
loyalty that you have to Sambas really
yeah that's funny so I'm so not a
sneaker head so I have like one pair of
shoe I think I'm wearing the same thing
I think I have one pair and I just
continue to wear them but I think super
fancy sneakers are too they're just like
too much going on
Sambas are classic they blend into your
outfit and wear a lot of Dickies I feel
like they look good with Dickies the
fashion sites there's tons of them that
are just line dedicated to the style
evolution of zoe kravitz so if you'll
humor me oh no what I want to do know
show you some throwbacks and I'm just
wondering how they hit your eyes now in
2020 okay so here you are 1997 MTV Movie
Awards literally wearing the jacket I'm
wearing right now literally no but could
be also maybe it looks like a Ring Pop
oh my god is it maybe I don't know oh
look at my toes I'm I was cool this is a
cool outfit I would wear this outfit
right now
let me show you another one here you are
this looks like 2002 Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show like why are you bringing
your kid to that um Oh God do you
remember that look yeah this is bummer
this is a bummer I was a victim to the
Kangol hat which is something that only
samuel l.jackson should wear no one else
except for you heard it here samuel
l.jackson just wear this hat oh I'm okay
I have a bag made out of candy wrappers
or something
look man I was confused this is a
confusing time but also what's my dad
wearing also let's see that could have
been a good wing that could have been a
good game what is my dad wearing with
this one where do you stand on vests now
oh no you're bullish who are you what
are you doing go home where are your
friends why didn't they tell you
alright zoe kravitz that's why just can
I just sure you can keep them it was
totally up to you this next one is to
bomb beyond insanity sky my friend's guy
right look at her scared happy yes I
brought my best friend in the world sky
who I've literally known since I was she
was there when I was born she was in the
room when I was born because her father
and my father are old friends and she's
six months older than me so she was in
the room so we are lifelong friends and
she's obsessed with the show she's the
reason I wanted to do this show thanks
for the referral sky skies loser [ __ ]
and she was hyped for da bomb yes she's
just like you're gonna try to bomb good
so this guy this is this is for you
[Music]
I just don't like the way this tastes
right well this about to [ __ ] me oh I
see you I see you alright this is just
make me want to like okay it's that part
of the trip you know
yes exactly truly this is the part we
are like okay okay I'm in this now I
don't know what specific drug that was
well speaking of that's such a poetic
segue cuz in your years of going to
Burning Man I'm curious what's the
craziest thing you've ever seen when we
had Cara Delevingne on the show she said
that she saw two people having sex what
wasn't sure if it was an art user is
gnarly [ __ ] just give me a minute I want
to make sure like absorb it experience
it I am and this is totally be careful
around your eyes don't touch your eyes
yes this guy told me that she credits
this is also the part in the show we're
like you guys do that thing to my voice
where it's like echoey and [ __ ] there
was one time where it was like 7:00 in
the morning and we hadn't gone to sleep
yet and then all of a sudden a hot-air
balloon came down and these people
jumped out and I think they handed us
like grilled cheese sandwiches or
something and Wow joke because we were
so hungry and hungover and you're sure
about Burning Man is that you get what
you need magically give any thoughts on
like Mark Zuckerberg helicoptering and a
Black Rock City or like Jeff Bezos bring
in private chefs and stuff like do
Instagram influencers and like tech
tycoons and they kind of like
threatening the spirit of Burning Man
yeah I mean when I first went there was
no cell phone service no one had that
you know we didn't have iPhones so there
was it was a really safe space so you
could walk around half naked on acid and
it was fine I wouldn't do that now
personally because I would be scared
someone who's taking a you know a
picture or something which is a bummer
and then there's also just like this
communal
feeling you know there's these things
called art cars and you can jump on and
jump off and anyone can jump on and jump
off and I remember going a few years ago
and a few friends of mine jumped on a
car and some girls were like this is
private actually and we were like this
that's not how this works [ __ ] like
what are you doing you know I'm happy
that powerful people with money and
influence are choosing to hopefully
expand their minds I think that's cool
but I think if you're gonna go to
something like that you should try and
honor what it's about and again if
you're gonna bring a five-star chef do
it but give food to whoever wants it hey
that's what I'm saying
all right the Zoe all right onda
nobody's running me too
you and I both
the whale maker can kill her husband's
mateship my taste buds are dead from the
bump yeah
as someone who's met prince open from
Miley Cyrus and been in a jay-z video do
you have a most cherished musical memory
in your life yeah hanging out with
Prince was always hanging out with
Prince yeah for someone to say yes and
then him performing too he would have
these parties he performed downstairs
and yeah it's a house at his house it's
nuts and then they give you pancakes
it's true it's like the rumors were true
you went to a prince house concert and
got pancakes yes and it starts at
midnight excuse me it starts at midnight
and then Prince performs and then they
give you pancakes it's like that is
Disneyland
that's what Disneyland should really be
which is a more intense fan base Harry
Potter fans are x-men fans Batman fans
you're feeling that already I'm feeling
the heat
no pun intended yeah
have you gotten a chance to try on the
Catwoman suit yeah I have it's cool it's
really cool the last day
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
right you don't have to if you don't
want to dude I haven't even drank water
yet I'm me I'm a year I'm ready I am
very humbled that's good that's good all
right oh you sound concerned for me are
you concerned sweet Cheers not uh not
not uh not miss no drink no water no
milk no beer zoe kravitz I'm not worried
about you this is so good a [ __ ] me
up after you said that all right zoe
kravitz here we are at the summit of
Mount Scoville all the way down the hot
ones gauntlet and we've touched on a lot
of things that are special and important
to zoe kravitz but one thing we haven't
talked about is your love of friends I
know that you spend many a late night
binge with friends so now that your
brain is on fire hot sauce circulating
through your veins I'm gonna hit you
with a quick friends quiz you just put
together by none other than fellow
friends superfan
Dominique burrows and hot ones producer
over there okay all right what is the
Joey special the Joey
Jew pizzas ding ding ding ding doesn't
even have to give the multiple choice
how did Monica and Ross's routine
originally end they did this on the New
Year's Eve special right yeah Monica
holding Ross Monica catching Roger
correct okay one more for you what high
school did Rachel Ross and Monica attend
Lincoln the answer is late and look at
you zoe kravitz knocking down friends
trivia taken down super spicy vegan
wings and not even a drop of milk water
or beer to show for it and now zoe
kravitz there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you my
friend okay this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in you everybody you know
I have a show up called high fidelity do
I look at all of them you know it's a
it's a choose-your-own-adventure okay
okay what's up I have a show called
height called high fidelity on Hulu it's
out February 14th which is Valentine's
Day I feel good Cheers here's my friend
[Music]
alright guys trying alright so I'm
joined today at the table with sky who
very thankfully referred Zoi to the show
without sky perhaps none of this is even
possible and you know after she's done
such a great thing for us we decided hey
we got to return the favor
and the way that we did that is by
soaking a vegan wing and a bomb and now
sky is going to live the show well this
is a big all right I'm just gonna don't
be scared okay
go in you're here alright sky do you
remember how you discovered oh you
taught me wow this is a kid you can wash
and wise
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans and as you know you can
catch me every Thursday in this little
black box interviewing celebrities but
what if I told you that there was a show
that actually had a decent set where we
fed even hotter wings to civilians while
asking them trivia questions well guess
what my friend that show exists and it's
called hot ones the game show hot ones
the game show on truTV
check your local listings we'll see you
in the peppered Oh
[Music]